معنا من مقر الامم المتحده في نيويورك
فرحان حق نائب المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده مرحبا بك سيد فرحان حق هل
تمكنت فرق الامم المتحده من احداث تقييم
اولي لابرز الاحتياجات لاسيما على صعيد
مساعده فرق الانقاذ من اجل
الاسراع في انقاذ الارواح
نحن بدانا في الامم المتحده ان نقوم
بتقييم بالاحتياجات لقد بدانا
محاولين ان نقرر ما هي الاحتياجات في
في جنوب تركيا وفي شمال غربي سوريا
بالتاكيد هذا الاحتياجات ستكون كبيره حتى
قبل هذه الهزه الارضيه فان الامم المتحده
والشركاء
نحاول نساعده
ما يصل الى 1.7 مليون شخص في شمالي سوريا
وبالتاكيد هذه المساعدات وهذا الرقم
سيزداد والحاجه والامكانيه لمساعده
الاشخاص ستكون اصعب بسبب الطرق المدمره
والممرات وامور اخرى بالتالي نحن بدانا
بتقييما للاحتياجات قد يتطلب الامر عده
ايام لاكتمال هذا التقييم هو ايضا نقوم في
نفس الوقت
باعاده
توزيعي وتعيين الاحتياجات الموجوده مثلا
المواد الغذائيه التي تكون اساسيه للناس
التي يحتاجونها لكن
بالاخذ بنظر الاعتبار حجم الدمار والناس
الذين اصبحوا بدون ماوى فان الحاجه ستكون
هائله ونحتاج نامل ان المجتمع الدولي
سيكون مهيئا لمساعده الناس في تركيا وفي
سوريا في موضوع سوريا تحديدا سيد فرحان
لان سوريا تعاني من ضعف كبير في البنيه
التحتيه ومن اثار حرب استمرت على مدى
سنوات ما نوع المخاوف او ما هي المخاوف
لدى المسؤولين في المنظمه الدوليه من
تداعيات هذا الزلزال على المجتمع هناك
لدينا الكثير من بواعث القلق حول كيفيه
تمكننا من تقديم المساعده للاشخاص الذين
كانوا بحاجه قبل لهذا الارضيه والان الناس
الذين اصبحوا بعد الهزه الارضيه بدون ماوى
وبدون منازل بالتالي هنالك الكثير من
القضايا المختلفه احدها ان لدينا نقطه
عبور حدوديه في باب الهوى وهذه هي النقطه
التي
خاصه ورخص مجلس الامن المرور من خلالها
وعلينا ان نرى ما مدى سهوله
حضور شحنات المساعدات في هذه النقطه
بالاقد بنظر الاعتبار الضرر الذي لحقه
بالطرقات الطرقات في تلك المنطقه بالتالي
علينا ان نقيم ما هي افضل الطرق لتقديم
المساعده بشكل فعال لمن يحتاجها هناك في
شمال غربي سوريا بالتاكيد الناس الذين
يعانون ايضا في منطقه غازي عنتاب في تركيا
هناك يعني يتواجد منظمات تابعه للامم
المتحده تنشط وتعمل هناك هل تستطيع الان
تكييف عملها مع المتطلبات التي
فرضتها او فرضها هذا الزلزال
بالتاكيد نامل ان شركائنا في العمل
الانساني باستطاعتهم ان يساعدوا من نشاطهم
لكن مره اخرى هنالك تحدي فرض علينا انه
ليست نزلت تقديم المساعده لكن
طواقيمنا على الارض هم عانوا انفسهم من
هذه الكارثه لا نعرف اذا ما كان بعضهم بعض
الخسائر في قمه الامم المتحده اعتقد انه
سيكون ذلك بعض منهم من ضمن الخسائر لكننا
نقوم باحصاء افراد طواقمنا في المنطقه
وانا ايضا المنظمات الانسانيه الموجوده
على الارض عليها ان تقوم بنفس الشيء
وعلينا ان نرى ما الذي يمكن ان نقوم به ما
هي اوضاع المخازن
والشاحنات التي تستخدم لنقل
الاغاثه وايضا من الذين نستطيع ان ننقده
الان لكي نستطيع ان نوصل المساعدات لمن
يحتاجها اشكرك من مقر الامم المتحده في
فرحان حق نائب المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده